hey guys it's Justine and I am so
excited the holidays are here and I
always hear in the comments that you
guys want me to do some giveaways I
don't do them very often but I thought
this is the season of giving so I am so
excited to announce ijustine's vlogmas
giveaway yeah I thought really hard
about that name
um yeah that's what we're sticking with
so starting on December 17th we're gonna
be announcing eight days of gifts to get
entries there's gonna be various things
that you'll have to do each day like
follow me on Twitter follow me on Tick
Tock subscribe to my YouTube channel
make sure you're on the mailing list
because that's actually where I'm going
to be giving out some extra bonus points
there will also be some secret codes in
some upcoming videos so make sure you
guys are paying attention for those as
well I'm so excited about this I had a
few Brands donate some products so I
cannot wait to share with you over the
next eight days I can't wait this is
gonna be so much fun again check out
ijustine.com vlogmas and I'll see you
there